we are continuing in the revision for uh
all of the hsc topics you've been
looking at in extension two and it's
still funny to me that there's just the
five of them right so we started at
complex numbers we then did proof we
went through vectors further integration
and then we finished up with mechanics
so those are the five topics you need to
master and being that we had a look at
3d vectors and proof last week i thought
yeah let's go back to integration it's
been a little while and we didn't get to
assess it in your previous task so you
can have a look here and just to refresh
your memory
you can see this uh let this notation of
the i the capital i for integral and
that that sort of subscript of an m this
is an indicator that you're dealing with
a recurrence relation or a reduction
formula different names for the same
thing so this is kind of our walmart
question though i i've said that a few
times this afternoon and i just want to
point out one of the reasons why i'm
giving you this question is because it
is question 8 of a previous hsc when
there used to be only eight questions in
the extension two paper and as a
consequence like it's it's tough um it's
so tough that less than a quarter of the
state were able to get this question
with full marks
maybe there was an element of fatigue
there like you've gotten to the end of
question 8 your brain is just fried but
there are some twists and turns in here
so it's 212 at the moment um i'd like to
give you guys about five minutes um even
if you know exactly what to do there's
still a fair bit of work to go through
and it is a proof question right so you
cannot skip any of your logic there you
have to really show you know what you're
doing in your integration by parts and
so on so i'm going to call it at a 218.
if uh you have not done if you're not
finished by 218 then please just pop a
message to mrs lee's or i and say i need
more time um but otherwise if you are
ready uh give us an indication some of
you have been having a go at this
question for a little bit and i can give
you a bit of a
a heads up about what the next question
will be
by direct message so we don't spoil it
for everyone um but being that some
people only just entered on time i'll
put myself back on mute i'll leave the
question on screen so you don't need to
take a screenshot or anything like that
and give us an indication one way or the
other if you are done or if you need
more time
all that that's all from me for the next
few minutes good luck
okay i call time uh hopefully that is
enough for those of you who feel like
you knew what you were doing and also
wasn't too long for those of you who
were just like i'm beating my head
against the brick wall so let me help
you out
when we have a look at this question um
what makes it challenging well there's a
couple of things firstly being that it's
a recurrence relation which we kind of
already signaled from the beginning we
know that integration by parts is almost
certainly going to be the way that that
comes out and the first thing that is
challenging about this is that is not
exactly a straightforward integration by
parts you're pretty used to saying oh
choose one of these as you and one of
them is dv and then off you go but here
be owing to the fact that there's um
these are algebraic right uh you
actually have to do a little bit of
manipulation to make the integration by
parts work work nicely anyway and not be
a complete dog's breakfast that's the
first thing and then the second thing is
you can see it's a second order
recurrence relation you've got this uh
nth integral with an x to the power of m
and then you've got this m minus 2th
integral
which means you're going to have an x to
the m minus 2 up here and so you've got
to sort of you might think are these two
steps that i have to go through so in
order to try and make clear how we
actually get this relationship and get
the proof the first thing i want to do
is notice that oopsy daisy
because i'm going to be looking for and
i
m minus 2 i think it is going to be
helpful for us to say well what is i
of m minus 2. so off to the side here
before i've even begun constructing my
proof i'm going to say well what is that
equal to if i just take the definition
of i
m because that will help me it's a bit
like in a you know when you're proving a
trigonometric identity um you get given
the the final result and you're like i'm
thinking like where is there a sec x
that will appear or where's the tan
squared you know that's your destination
so that guides the simplification that
you do so what is i
of n minus 2
the only place that m appears in this
definite integral is just up here in
this power right x to the power of m so
i'm going to substitute that for an m
minus 2 and then when i have a look at
the rest of the integrand it's
independent of m so i can somewhat well
i'm not going to ignore it but i'm not
going to make any changes to it yeah so
it's going to be x squared minus 1 to
the power of 5
d
x so i'm going to file that away for
later i'm hoping that i'm going to go
through integration by parts that
term or that whole expression there on
the right hand side is going to appear
somewhere and then i can do some you
know rearrangement and algebraic
manipulation to get to the required
result
all right so let's make a start on
actually dealing with this integral now
like i said before um the first thing
that is is non-trivial about this maybe
this is why some of you are stuck and
you're like oh i couldn't even progress
very far is that choosing either x to
the m or x squared minus one to the five
choosing either them as u or dv
neither of them are
really set up nicely to actually end up
on the result that you want
so we actually have to do a teeny bit of
manipulation to help us right now what i
would suggest is when you think about um
yoga i've mentioned to you um i like to
think about which one should be dv right
because you know you're going to
integrate that so what's the thing
that's easy to integrate
either of these are relatively simple to
integrate but if you've tried this
you've found that it's it's not going to
get towards this because when you
integrate x to the m you get
x to the m plus one on m plus one so
you're going further away from i
m minus two you're getting i of m plus
one and some other stuff right so that's
why this is not a good candidate
candidate for dv it's just as easy to
integrate it just doesn't get you toward
this recurrence relation so that's the
first thing i want to signal the second
thing is when you have a look at this
term here right this x squared minus 1
to the 5.
it
by comparison looks terrible to
integrate you're like
gross like i have to use reverse chain
rule but then
when you're thinking about how to use
reverse chain rule you need the inside
derivative to appear and there is no
inside derivative it would be 2x in this
case right
but this is i've sort of flagged this
earlier right even though 2x does not
appear something very much like it is
still accessible nearby right it's not a
2x but there's a whole bunch of x's in
that x to the m term there's m of them
so i can just borrow one out of there
it's not the same as 2x but it's only
off by a constant coefficient so i think
that's good enough for me
so therefore here's what i'm going to
write i'm going to say let's break apart
that x to the m
into an x to the m minus 1
and an x right which looks not simpler
but it will help us with the integration
by parts that's about to ensue i'm then
going to get x squared minus 1 to the 5
dx there's no change there and now i'm
ready to choose what will be my u and
what will be my dv right as i kind of
flagged earlier i'm going to suggest
that rather than choosing the x to the n
minus 1 term as dv which integrates and
goes away from i want to go down not up
i'm going to choose that as u so that's
x to the m minus one
and then uh when you think about uh
differentiating that it's pretty
straightforward right so you pull the
power out the front so this is d u on dx
is gonna be m minus one
x to the m minus two and that's your
first indication that you're like oh ooh
m minus two that's promising right i
need one of those yeah so that's sort of
already um a good sign for us
uh let's do the rest of the integration
in my parts so i'm going to get my dv on
dx now remember what i did was i pulled
out this x so that i can do reverse
chain rule on this whole term nice and
simply right so what am i going to get
here i've got x outside of x squared
minus one on
to the power of five
which i guess you could say oopsie daisy
i guess you could say is like uh i'm
going to put a half out the front and
then multiply by a 2 in there because
now look at that that's like perfectly
in reverse chain rule setup i've got the
f dash the 2x
as compared to the f which is x squared
minus 1. so that's pretty much ready to
go when i integrate this to get my v
what is going to happen well i'm going
to raise the power
so that's going to give me x squared
minus 1 to the power of 6.
um i'm going to divide through by that
2x because that was the inside
derivative and then i'm going to divide
by the new power now i've already got a
half at the front so when you divide a
half by the new power which is 6 you're
going to get 1 over 12. so there is my v
having integrated okay